Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
Video wie ihr seht stehe ich vor
pifgeist denn ich habe vor einiger Zeit
bei den Jungs von Goldies gesehen dass
pgeist neben dem normalen Menü noch ein
geheimes Menü hat und das werden wir
heute testen wir reden von Präsidenten
Cheeseburgern von Bacon milkshakes und
von grilled Cheeseburgern also wirklich
Sachen die es in sich haben finden wir
heraus ob es die Sachen wirklich gibt
und bestellen wir uns ein bisschen durch
die Karte los geht's ist ja die Hölle
los zwischen den Weihnachtsfeiertagen
hier ich hätte nicht gedacht dass so
viel los ist hallo hi wir nehmen bitte
einmal ein Grill cheese mit extra Petty
auf diesem Petty noch Käse Ketchup sent
Mayo gegrillte Zwiebeln und Pickel ein
little Cheeseburger mit dog also
Hotdog geht nicht okay kann man das
extra kan in
so okay dann mach gerne eine extra dann
bauen wir uns das selbst zusammen dann
den little Cheeseburger bitte mit Mayo
grilled onions Ketchup hot saauce
Pickles und Tomate dann nehmen wir noch
ein vanillemilkshake mit Bacon
funktioniert wirklich hätte nicht
gedacht dass das wirklich gibt ein
little Cheeseburger als lettuce wrap
also mit Salat gibt auch dann würde ich
einmal einen Cheeseburger mit lettuce
Tomaten Jalapenos und Senf nehmen weil
den scheinbar immer Barack Obama
bestellt hat in Amerika eine letzte
Sache könnte ich ein paar Fries haben
aber well done s das macht ihr nicht die
werden alle gleich lang frittiert okay
dann mach einfach eine normale Portion K
price bitte dazu ja let's go Alter hat
alles geklappt hätte ich nicht gedacht
wir konnen wirklich einfach alles
bestellen das waren zum größen Teil so
recipe Hacks so aus Amerika und so aber
trotzdem hat geklappt also normalerweise
wenn du irgendwie probierst so ein
McDonald's Menu Hack zu machen es
funktioniert nie so weil es einfach
anders ist diese Automaten sind auch
legendär ne Fanta Zero great unser
Milkshake ist schon fertig mit Bacon da
sind jetzt baconstücke
drin ein paar fre Erdnüsse dürfen nicht
fehlen ein alter Trick
[Musik]
ne danke schön das viel aber sind auch
vier Burger Freunde ich habe schon
gesehen ein kleiner fail ist uns beim
Bestellen unterlaufen ihr werdet später
sehen so Freunde es wird Zeit für ein
gesundes Frühstück und Mittagessen die
letzten Tage fürstliches Weihnachtsessen
gegessen an der Stelle möchte ich
natürlich auch noch mal sagen dass ich
euch allen einen guten Rutsch wünsche
falls ihr das am 31 schaut falls ihr
später schaut viel Spaß mit dem Video so
schauen wir mal rein hier sitzen wir
jetzt vor unserer 44 € fivegist
Bestellung wir haben ein Bacon Vanille
Milkshake und eine vielfall von Burger
ihr wisst ja genau was wir gerade
bestellt haben aber den Bacon Vanille
Milkshake möchte ich als allererstes
probieren bevor er vollkommen
geschmolzen ist kann mir wirklich nicht
vorstellen wie das schmecken soll aber
ihr seht es hier five guys Milkshake mit
extra Bacon okay probieren wir den
Vanille Bacon Milkshake du h so ein
klein bisschen Crunch und so ein Hauch
von Bacon aber ich finde wenn man Bacon
Milkshake hört dann denkt man an so eine
Perversion von Milkshake der nach Bacon
schmeckt das schmeckt nach
vanillemilkshake mit Bacon manchmal hast
du so ein crunchy bite würde ich das
eher als normalen Milkshake bestellen
eigentlich nicht ich glaube ich würde
immer normal Milkshake bestellen weil es
macht eigentlich nicht es macht nur
komischer es macht nicht besser es macht
nur komischer aber es macht auch nicht
wirklich schlechter aber es pervers kann
man nicht anders sagen so dann schauen
wir mal alles wurde feinstens für uns
durchneriert erstmal ganz kurz wir haben
uns wieder ein paar Erdnüsse geschnappt
was nicht jeder weiß bei pifis wird
alles mit Erdnussöl gemacht Pommes
werden in Erdnussöl frittiert die pties
werden in erdnusöl gebraten dann
schmeckt auch hat so ein besonderen
Touch so ein besonderen Geschmack kommen
wir zu unserem ersten Burger dem One CB
mit Salat Tomaten sen und Jalapeno das
ist der Obama Burger diesen Burger so
wie ich ih hier in meiner Hand halte
bestellt anscheinend Barack Obama mit
Vorliebe zwei petties oben haben wir
Senf Salat Tomaten keine Ketchup keine
Mayo und unten ein paar slies Jalapenos
so für diesen extra Schärfe Kick dann
wollen wir mal probieren und schauen wir
ob Barack Obama guten Geschmack
hat ich finde immer man denkt bei
Burgern so wie groß kann der Unterschied
sein aber er kann gigantisch sein denk
mal an den Burger King warpper der so
ein ikonischen Geschmack hat denkt an
McDonald's Cheeseburger den auch jeder
von euch kennt und auch dieser Burger
ist sehr charakteristisch sehr eigen
dadurch dass du nicht Ketchup nicht Mayo
hast was auch VI vi Burgern vertreten
ist hat er wirklich ein besonderen
Geschmack die Jalapenos die von unten
durchkommen haben eine schöne dezente
Schärfe es fühlt sich sehr amerikanisch
an also jeder Burger fühlt sich sehr
amerikanisch an aber dieser besonders
vielleicht liegt an Obama vielleicht
liegt an diesen sehr touristischen
Zutaten mit der Addition von
schualapenos die für den gewissen Kitzel
am gaum sorgen SP kann zu viel reden
aber der Burger es klingt ein bisschen
dumm aber wirkt so lowy gesund neiniß
mal rein weil da so wenig Soße drauf ist
weiß du der triebt nicht soi mal rein
Zeug dich vom Gegenteil also gesund ist
er nicht aber diese jalapen ist schon
geile burgerkreation selbstverständlich
werfen wir nichts weg s bringen das den
Jungs mit ins Büro bei der nächsten
Bestellung hätte es beinah nicht
geklappt wir haben einen little
Cheeseburger mit mayio Gurke Tomaten
Zwiebeln und Hot saauce und eigentlich
wollte ich mir da noch so ein ein dog
drauf konfigurieren also ein Hotdog so
wie es sie hier gibt aber wir haben es
ja geregelt bekommen indem wir uns
separat noch einmal den dog bestellt
haben also wir bauen uns jetzt einfach
selbst zusammen das hier ist unser
little Cheeseburger ich weiß nicht genau
ob die Konfiguration von den godies
Jungs kam aber mit der Hot saauce mit
den gegrähten Zwiebeln mit allem klingt
das für mich wirklich nach einem sehr
sehr sehr sehr geilen Burger den wir
jetzt abermals pimpen indem wir hier
oben drauf den gegrillten Hotdog legen
das ist wirklich einfach pervers oder
also wow der eine ist für den Kameramann
passt du den ganz oh also wirklich ein
vielversprechender Burger der jetzt noch
vielversprechender wurde das ist unser
Menu Hack indem wir nicht nur einen
Burger sondern einen Hotdog Burger haben
den findet man hier so garantiert nicht
auf der Karte aber schauen wir mal ob
der Mehraufwand ist wert ist boah es
sieht wirklich einfach nur perv aus ne
wow ich bin jetzt schon verliebt ne wenn
das jetzt auch noch gut schmeckt es
könnte ohne Witz mein neuer
lieblingspipgeistburger werden echt also
das ist so pervers wow diese mayio mit
der Hot saauce dann so dieser sehr sehr
krasse fleischige Geschmack so der noch
viel weiter geht als beim normalen
einfachen Paty das ist wirklich so ein
umami Boost dazu Cremigkeit von Mario
das ich würde jetzt soweit gehen und
sagen dass diese Hot Sauce mayio Kombi
auf jeden fivegeist Burger drauf gehört
also wenn ihr bei F seid ihr müsst nicht
so ein verrückten menuack bestellen aber
macht mal Hotz und Mario auf einem
Burger drauf unglaublich upside down ups
ich verstehe komplett was du meinst mit
diesem dass das mehr als ein Petty
schmeckt al so mehr Fleischgeschmack mit
sich bringt als ein PTY alleine ja die
sausage das ist nicht so eine normale
Wiener Wurst oder so die hat auch eine
Würzung so eine rinswurst glaube ich
weiß ich nicht aber ist auch so mit
Paprika noch gewürzt man merkt so das
ist einfach geil vor es weitergeht
kümmern wir uns einmal um unsere pomes
das sind keine normalen das sind CEN
Style aber CEN Style steht auf der Karte
deshalb ist es kein Menu Hack das sind
einfach so sehr würzige Pommes ich mache
das schon immer so ich weiß noch das
erste Mal bei pgist war ich in Paris und
als ich irgendwann gehört habe dass nach
Deutschland kommt bin ich wirklich
komplett mental gegangen bin damals
direkt nach Oberhausen gefahren als der
erste dort aufgemacht hat aber hier seht
ihr was eine kleine Portion PIs price
ist ist immer absurd viel aber das ist
nicht der eigentliche Heck wie gesagt
das sind diese stark gewürzten CEN Style
Fries aber der eigentliche Heck kommt
jetzt ihr bestellt euch Senf nehmt euch
ein bisschen Ketchup ein bisschen Mayo
dann machen wir uns ganz schnell hier in
diesem schellchen die bekannte in and
out animal Style Soße eigentlich in
jedem Laden ist die secret burgersoßce
eine Mischung aus Ketchup Senf Mayo und
vielleicht no ein bisschen Gurkenwasser
und Gurkenstückchen aber wenn wir das
jetzt vermischen erhalten wir die animal
Style Soße die zugegebenermaßen echt
sehr sehr geil ist und pfeifgeist macht
gar nichts so mit so einer verrückten
Soße oder so deshalb ist das ein sehr
cooler Trick um seine Fries oder seine
Burger aufzupimpen man mischt sich
einfach diese Soße hier zusammen
schüttelt sie über jeden Burger drüber
oder ist sie zu pomes und dann hat man
ein wenig in and out ein bisschen
kalifornisches Gefühl in dem Pfeife ist
egal wo auf der Welt animal Style Soße C
and Fries probieren wir also es ist kein
Wunder dass jeder Burgerladen sagt dass
das die geheime burgersoße ist es ist
geil eigentlich hatten wir vor die Fries
well done zu bestellen was nichts
anderes heißt als länger frittiert und
extra crispy genau extra crispy das
funktioniert scheinbar in Amerika bei
uns in Deutschland nicht aber mit diesem
Menu Hack könnt ihr eure Fries auf jeden
Fall ein wenig aufempen als nächstes
kommt etwas das ein bisschen anders
gelaufen ist als gedacht wir haben ein
salad wrap bestellt der befindet sich
hier drin und merkt wirklich schon dass
es einfach die Hälfte wiegt von den
normalen Burgern vielleicht ist uns ein
kleiner Fehler unterlaufen wir packen
einfach mal aus und wir sehen Salat jede
Menge Salat es sieht wirklich an und für
sich schon mal vollkommen eigenartig aus
dieser salatwrap einfach so ein paar
Blätter Eisbergsalat der sogar
erstaunlich knusprig noch ist obwohl er
hier eingepackt ist weil der dämpft ja
quasi darin wenn wir jetzt aber mal
aufmachen sehen wir das ist einfach nur
ein Burger pettty mit Käse ich habe
nämlich ein little Cheeseburger als
salatwrap bestellt und da ist keine Soße
keine champing kein nichts so wie er
jetzt ist und ich glaub das ist
wahrscheinlich auch der einzige Grund
warum man das bestellt ist er perfekt
für eine ketogene Ernährung also ich
weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
Attacke ohne Witz viel besser als ich
gedacht hätte ich das sieht so falsch
aus also ist natürlich lange nicht so
gut wie ein normaler Burger es fehlt
einfach ein bisschen was sagen wir so
wie es ist aber ich habe es mir
irgendwie noch absurder und trauriger
vorgestellt ALR nehmen wir auch mit und
dann kommen wir auch schon zum
krassesten Burger des heutigen Tages und
das Besondere ist dass dieser Burger
eigentlich kein Burger ist ist sondern
es ist ein grilled cheese Sandwich
welches wir mit einem kleinen Trick zu
einem Burger gemacht haben und ihr
werdet sofort sehen was die Besonderheit
ist five guys bereitet sein Grill cheese
Sandwich nämlich Inside Out vor also du
hast quasi normales burgerbrot was aber
innen angetastet wird und dann um 180°
gedreht wird und so haben wir wirklich
diesen sehr einzigartigen Anblick der
diesen Burger hier auszeichnet es ist
irgendwie echt schon cool also ich Kön
mir vorstellen dass eine Burgerkette
diesen Style so zu ihrem Twist macht so
weißt du also ich sehe eine Burger kätte
genau das machen und auf der ganzen Welt
erfolgreich werden so weil Leute sagen
so ja das coole ist dass sie ihre Bands
falsch rum haben klar so ein Burger Ban
schützt natürlich vor allem deine Finger
auch davon so ein bisschen sehr fettig
zu werden das wird in ordentlich Fett
hier angeröstet und dementsprechend
sehen auch deine Finger aus wenn du da
dran fasst aber darauf haben wir jetzt
ein Grill cheese mit extra PY und auf
diesem PY noch Käse Ketchup Senf Mayo
gegrillt Zwiebeln und Pickles also auch
hier nur geilen scheiß wir haben alle
drei socen wir haben eine schöne dicke
Picke und auch wenn ihr jetzt genauso
schmeckt wie der normale bestellt i beim
nächsten Mal wenn ihr mit EUR mein
Freund bei FG se einfach um zu zeigen
dass ihr mehr wisst als sie ja das so
ein partytck ja genau probieren wir den
Inside Out
Burger direkt sehr sehr starke
Cheeseburger Vibes McDonald's
Cheeseburger Vibes weil ich hatte diese
Pickel ich hatte Senf ich hatte Ketchup
aber dieses
vollgesogene grilled cheese Patty ich
glaube die benutzen unter Garantie mehr
Fett mehr Butter für dieses greay cheese
als wenn die normales Bann anrösten weil
du hast so dieses süßlich fettige von
ban was einfach so den ganzen Burger
dominiert also da kommt eine ganz andere
Geschmackskomponente mit rein es geht
hierbei wirklich nicht nur ums Aussehen
sondern das ändert geschmacklich viel
was soll ich sagen Leute ich glaube ich
war noch nie in dem videodre so nah aner
herzkranzverfettung das gibt oder weiß
noch einmal rein weil einfach zu gut
schmeckt man sieht wirklich dass die
obere Schicht vom Ban in Fett
karamellisiert ist und das schmeckt man
wirklich weiß du auch noch mal rein hat
gerade schon abgebissen ich habe
vergessen zu filmen ich bin nicht der
Kameramann guck dir diese absolute
Perversion an die buttrigkeit ist CRA
oder das Ban schmeckt ganz anders wie du
gesagt hast weiß aber auch nicht ob nur
besser weiß nicht ob das zu einem
herzhaften Burger den ich haben möchte
in dem Moment 100% so passt die Idee das
andersrum anzubraten die will ich aber
auch mal zu Hause ausprobieren das finde
ich schon sehr sehr genial ja okay Leute
wir haben uns alles eingepackt und haben
die komplette Tüte demoliert kommen wir
zum Ranking anstatt euch jetzt jeden
Platz zu geben sage ich euch einfach was
mir am Besten und was mir am
schlechtesten gefallen hat am
schlechtesten gefallen heute ihr wisst
es der salad wrap also der salatburger
weil es fehlt einfach was von ein
richtig geilen Burger wenn er in Salat
eingepackt ist sorry an alle die sich
Keto ernähren es ist einfach nicht das
Gleiche trotzdem überraschend gut aber
lange nicht so gut wie die anderen und
vor allem lange nicht so gut wie der
little Cheeseburger mit dem Hotdog wow
insbesondere in dieser soßenkombination
die wir bestellt haben wirklich crazy es
hat mein es hat mein Leben verändert
möchte ich sagen dieses Video zu drehen
deshalb noch mal vielen vielen Dank an
die Goldies Jungs die mich auf die Idee
gebracht haben und die einige von diesen
Bestellung hier gezeigt haben man kann
Spaß haben wenn man mit offenen Augen
durchs Leben geht deshalb probiert euch
a habt Spaß genießt das neue Jahr und ja
vielleicht könnt ihr dies Video noch mal
anschauen wenn ihr Sport durchzieht und
Ernährung durchzieht und euch einen
kleinen cheed im Kopf genehmigen wollt
deshalb das war komisch aber irgendwie
auch gut